les électeurs de la deuxième
circonscription des Yvelines sont
appelés à voter les deux et 9 octobre
prochain Jean-Noël barreau avait été élu
avec 64,27% des voix en juin dernier à
l'époque 11 candidats s'étaient déclarés
ils ne seront plus que 6 pour cette
élection partielle c'est une élection
majeure dans dans la période que nous
traversons face aux crises immenses qui
sont devant nous nous avons besoin de
stabilité au gouvernement comme au
Parlement à mes côtés
sera Anne bergante qui est une femme
engagée élue depuis 2008 à
lévis-saint-non dans la vallée de
Chevreuse avec laquelle nous partageons
des valeurs fortes et la conviction que
nous devons préserver le cadre de vie de
notre circonscription face à lui la
candidate nupes Maïté qui arrive
bedouani qui avec
22,66% des voix c'était qualifiant
dernier pour le second tour je me
surprétée parce que je continue le même
combat j'estime qu'il y a une nécessité
de pouvoir engager
réellement une transition écologique et
une transition de justice sociale il y a
deux enjeux aujourd'hui et deux urgences
il y a l'urgence de fin de mois et puis
nous devons prendre en compte
tout ce qui est rénovation thermique
pour pouvoir passer l'hiver le
rassemblement national a changé de
candidat Gaëtan Brou candidat au mois de
juin à cette des sa place à anne-jakma
qui s'était présenté elle dont la
première circonscription nous sommes
l'alternative et nous sommes nous sommes
l'alternance à Emmanuel Macron
et m'inscrire dans le groupe j'irai
d'être la voix de plus au service de la
deuxième circonscription qu'il mérite
bien d'avoir un député qui ne va pas
seulement chercher un poste pour son
intérêt personnel mais qui d'abord
veut défendre les Français et donc les
Yvelinois la deuxième circonscription
c'est bien une priorité dans la famille
de la droite conservatrice on trouve
également Laurence Trochu présidente du
mouvement conservateur
qui rejoint reconquête d'Éric Zemmour
très clairement aujourd'hui dans cette
élection ce qui se joue c'est deux
visions du monde celle de Jean-Noël
Barrault qui en bon ministre d'Emmanuel
Macron continue cette déconstruction de
notre identité de notre souveraineté et
de l'école et puis cette vision que je
que je défends qui est une vision
enracinée qui est une vision qui nous
fait retrouver la grandeur et la
puissance de notre pays côté droit de
républicaine Pascal Thevenot c'est lui
qui a obtenu l'annulation de l'élection
ancien députée de cette circonscription
mais éliminer dès le premier tour au
mois de juin dernier estime que cette
fois les électeurs se sentiront plus
libres de voter pour leur conviction
depuis 10 ans finalement on se rend
compte que et les gens commencent à en
prendre conscience c'est la première
fois qu'ils peuvent voter par conviction
et pas par défaut et finalement le vote
utile c'est moi puisque les majorités
sont faites avec une majorité inattendue
mais
finalement la droite et le centre est
venu le pivot et c'est l'occasion même
dans cette assemblée sans majorité de
pouvoir mener une politique de réformes
qui est attendue enfin pour clore les
disques candidat qui se présente pour la
cinquième fois dans cette
circonscription c'est Pascal Casimir
Périer qui dit s'inscrire dans la
majorité présidentielle et revendique
ses attaches locales moi je défends une
candidature locale je suis de
Magny-les-Hameaux j'habite là depuis
l'âge de 4 ans je suis allé à la
maternelle au collège je suis allé aussi
au lycée Jules Ferry à Versailles qui
est aussi sur la deuxième
circonscription et j'ai fait mon service
militaire où ça à Villacoublay j'étais
chauffeur d'état-major donc je suis
vraiment raciné dans les Yvelines et je
veux être un député de terrain pour
défendre des intérêts de des habitants
des Yvelines c'est si candidats
parviendront-ils à mobiliser les
électeurs la question de l'abstention
comme dans toute élection partielle sera
la clé de ce scrutin